[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section we
loved watching Disney Princesses when we
were kids but now that we are grownups
we realized that many of these stories
never made sense once you hear about all
the unanswered questions that fans have
you will never watch those movies the
same way again just wait until you hear
why the pig in moaña
stayed behind if you love Disney as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you ten unanswered
questions from Disney movies Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs everyone was amazed
by the first full-length animated
feature in motion picture history and as
the first Disney Princess in 1937
this movie was not only created for the
kids at the time but also for grownups
this is why we wondered why they didn't
ask themselves more questions when they
watched this fairy tale at the end of
the story Snow White was saved by the
kiss of a prince they got married and
mrs. Umi had the chance to see the first
happily ever after did you know that
Snow White was only 14 years old in the
story that's way too young to get
married
and we can't believe that the prince was
the love of her life after singing a
duet together kissing a random corpse in
the middle of the forest is not really
romantic either he was not the only man
who did weird things when you pay
attention to the dwarves what have they
been doing with all the diamonds they
mine every day if they could simply sell
them they would be rich and they
wouldn't be living in that small house
they don't look like they are working
for anyone so no one could take these
precious stones away from them we just
hope these characters would have been
just as nice with the princess if they
were rich Cinderella this is probably
the most memorable fairy tale of all
time everyone remembers this rags to
riches story and hope that they will one
day be saved by the love of their lives
but has grown up to the 21st century we
think that this story is not romantic at
all
why can't Cinderella
try to escape and tell everyone how her
stepmother was treating her we know that
it's hard to escape an abusive
relationship but that doesn't mean that
we should cow little girls to wait for
their prince charming to save them and
this prince wasn't really charming after
all he spent one night with her and he
couldn't even remember her face if she
were really the love of his life he
would have just looked at all the young
women in the kingdom until he found her
instead of making everyone try on this
shoe and this shoe is probably the
weirdest part of the story
at midnight everything turned back to
normal the coach turned back into a
pumpkin her animal friends reverted to
their original form and her dress was in
tatters and why did the shoes stay the
same in this case
why didn't just disappear like
everything else we also wonder what
would have happened if another girl hid
in the glass slipper before Cinderella
had a chance to try it the prince not so
charming would probably marry the
stranger anyway Sleeping Beauty if you
think that Cinderella was not really
romantic after all you're not ready for
Sleeping Beauty once again it was the
story of a girl who fell in a deep sleep
and was saved by the kiss of a prince
this is why Disney wanted to make sure
that it was really different from Snow
White in the Seven Dwarves the first
thing we think about when we watched the
third disney princess movie is why the
parents didn't just invite Maleficent we
know that no one really appreciated her
and it would have been better than
facing her revenge anyways she wasn't
that good it took her years to find the
young princess
why didn't she simply send her raven
Diablo to locate her in the first place
she wouldn't have wasted so much time
she managed to find a way to make aurora
fall in a deep sleep anyway and the lead
role in the movie was in bed for the
rest of the time but how did she survive
all this time without food or water she
wasn't at the hospital with people
taking care of her but what made us
cringe the most was the kiss at the end
of the movie has anyone told this prince
that it's not okay to kiss strangers
when they're sleeping someone should
teach these young Disney fans about
consent that Little Mermaid we asked way
too many questions about this movie
because so many things didn't make sense
at all and others were just totally
ridiculous
first let's admit it we know that area
lost her voice but she knew how to write
as we could see when she signed a
contract with Ursula why didn't she just
tell Eric about what happened so he
would understand that this kiss was
really important for her the movie would
have been a little boring but it would
have been much simpler for the young
princess but there are many other weird
things that we saw in this movie
how was she okay with a crab bean served
for dinner this poor creature was
probably one of her friends under the
sea another thing some fans wondered
about is why Sebastian had an accent
unlike all the other characters did he
travel that far to get there he was not
a strong swimmer and probably wouldn't
survive in the cold water Ursula is
another weird character why did she used
to live in a palace why was she banished
and most importantly how can she paint
her nails underwater anyway we think
that the Little Mermaid teaches us one
lesson that young girls should never
listen to don't change who you are just
to please a man he will never love the
real you so will never be worth it
Beauty and the Beast we can't believe
that Disney found a way to turn this
terrifying story into something romantic
think about this the Beast kidnapped
Belle's father and she decided to take
his place and stay in the castle with
him forever then she made him a better
man and they decided to live happily
ever after together as grown-ups we
understand that most people would never
change
kidnapping is something a girl should
never forgive and she shouldn't even
expect someone to change but this
inappropriate love story was not the
only thing that didn't make sense in the
movie why did a witch curse a kid for
being a brat the Beast was really young
at the time and we think that simply
talking to him about this would have
been a good way to make him a better man
where were his parents in the story
anyway
and it doesn't make sense that we can
see a painting of the grown up beasts in
the castle when he was only a boy when
he was cursed there is no way anyone
would know what he was going to look
like anyway let's believe in this love
story for a moment at the end of the
movie beast told Belle that she could
save her father but why didn't she
simply say that she was going to come
back the Beast wouldn't have to worry
all this time Belle wasn't so smart
after all Pocahontas
this was the first Disney princess movie
inspired by a true story however just
because it was based on something real
doesn't mean that it would totally make
sense this is probably why many people
think that the Disney movie doesn't look
like the original story at all
the most important thing that we
wondered about was how Pocahontas was
even able to talk to John she was a
Native American who had never seen white
men so there is no way she would have
known even one word of English but that
didn't stop them from being good friends
in the movie it's so weird to think that
Pocahontas was only a kid when she met
John Smith in real life many people who
know about this story have been
wondering why they decided to make her
older so they would fall in love with
each other what really happened was not
romantic at all and it was far from a
fairy tale but if they wanted to talk
about a young woman who really existed
why couldn't they talk about what
actually happened to her we will let you
answer that question
do you prefer Pocahontas in the Disney
movie or do you think that they should
have told us what really happened to her
don't be shy to tell us what you think
in the comment section down below
Aladin here comes Prince Ollie with some
much magic in this story we thought that
the story wouldn't really have to make
sense but we're still left with many
questions unanswered after watching the
movie and you will have to watch this
video a little more to know which
question was answered but let's start
with the genies magic power he was
supposed to make any wish come true
right but it seems like Aladdin was not
actually a prince he just looked like
one after all we never saw his kingdom
and what happened to all those people
who were serving him and how did you far
find out that he was only a common
street rat if he was supposed to be a
real Prince the genie was probably not
that good after all we have also been
wondering who was the magic carpet after
all it had a personality and it was one
of the most important characters it was
not only a carpet and it deserved a name
right well someone revealed the carpet
actually had a secret name the Disney
team gave him an internal name while
they were working on the movie and we
were surprised to know that it was
simply brow foods out that such a
magical character could have such a
simple name only the biggest Disney fans
know about this and you are now part of
them
Tango's we all felt like Rapunzel at
some point in our life we lived in the
world protected from any danger and how
we realized that we were not really
living our lives and we decided to take
risks this experiences also what made us
realize that many things don't really
make sense in this story
how did Mother Gothel figure out the
right song to activate the powers of
Rapunzel's hair it probably took a lot
of time if she just tried to use any
words together we also wonder why Mother
Gothel didn't simply lie about
Rapunzel's birthday if she believed that
she was born on another day she wouldn't
think that all those lights in the sky
were for her it would also be harder for
people to understand that she was the
princess why didn't she try to escape
her tower before her 18th birthday
anyway she knew that people were living
there and she never wondered why she was
the only one stuck in a tower and there
was actually one really dangerous thing
in her room how was she even able to
hold her head up her hair probably
weighed way too much for her to live
like that at least we're happy to see
that the love story made more sense this
time yes
she fell in love with a thief but at
least she tried to hit him with a pan
before she found out that he was
actually very nice frozen even if you
have never watched this movie you all
remember it because everyone was singing
let it go that year we also watched it
so many times that we found out that
some things didn't make sense in this
story we never really understood why
Anna had to stay in the castle and have
no one else to play with
people thought that Elsa was dangerous
so it makes sense that she was always
locked in her room but Waggoner her
little sister have to be punished too
later in the movie we also met one of
the funniest Disney characters in the
world Olaf he dreamed of living in this
summer and people didn't want to tell
him that it was impossible but why
didn't Olaf melt when they were visiting
the trolls there was no snow around this
place and there were even steam geysers
nearby we guessed that animators found
out too late that it didn't make sense
and they hope that no one would notice
but the most important question will
always be where do all his powers come
from Disney already explained why some
characters were special for example
Peter Pan used pixie dust and the Beast
was cursed but no one ever explained why
also had those magic powers since she
was a kid and why no one else in her
family had them this is something we
would like to see in another movie Moana
she may be one of the latest Disney
Princesses but there are still some
things that don't make sense in this
story this is why fans tried to find an
answer to their questions
many people have been wondering why puah
the pig stayed behind after all Moana
wanted to travel with him when she first
tried to use a boat but he almost
drowned we thought that she wouldn't be
traveling with anyone because it was too
dangerous but hey hey the rooster
accidentally joined her on her journey
however we saw poo on the boat for the
promotional pictures and this is why
fans couldn't believe that he wasn't a
part of the adventure this is why there
were so many theories some people think
that's who it doesn't exist and never
did
he was just mallanna's imaginary friend
when she was on the island other people
think that the pig was a symbol of what
Moana wanted her parents approval then
there are people who think that who had
never actually made it and others think
that he is a ghost of Mona's friends who
drowned but we still have many other
questions
why were there coconut pirates what
about the giant stinging crab how did
grandma knows so much about
reincarnation if you know any of the
answers to the questions we asked in
this video don't be shy to write it in
the comment section down below we'd love
to hear what you think and that's it for
10 unanswered questions from Disney
movies for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 desi princes
connections that will make your jaw drop
thanks for watching
[Music]